on se calme tout de suite ce n'est
peut-être pas si grave que ça c'est vrai
que je vais probablement faire souffler
chauffard se fait froid mais tout
d'abord javené toute manière prévu de
vous dire que pour commencer il n'y a
pas de crise environnementale
ça va bien en fait cette information est
tout à fait sérieuse elle est basée sur
l'information scientifique très
important publiée l'année dernière dans
une rue très prestigieuse dans
l'occurrence la rue saillants sais c'est
pas tout lire façon c'est trop petit une
information qui a été également présenté
à l'occasion d'un colloque international
très important de géologie en effet
c'est du bien de géorgie qui a lieu
chaque quatre années et cette
information a eu un très grand impact
dans la communauté scientifique mais
également dans la presse internationale
et pouvez voir ici des revues aussi
prestigieuses que des économistes le
monde
spiegel et c est cette info qu'est ce
que nous ont dit de quoi s'agit-il d'un
profondément ces scientifiques nous
disent qu on pendant cette année c'est
un groupe international de 35 personnes
ont étudié l'état global de la planète
et son évolution récente et sont arrivés
à la conclusion que nous étions sortis
de l'état qui prévalait sur notre terre
depuis la fin des dernières créations il
ya 10 2010 10 mille ans pardon et qui a
permis à notre espèce homo sapiens de
pro specie de prospérer et de se
développer jusqu'à présent on a parlé on
a parlé d'une époque qu'on ait un
critère qui a été dénommée l'holocène
mais ce qu affirment ces scientifiques
c'est que nous étions sortis de cet état
que nous avions amené la terre dans un
nouvel état qui promenait d'appeler
maintenant anthropocène et c'est
justement pour cette raison que le mot
crise ne convient pas parce que le mot
crise finalement on doit garder ce mot
crise pour décrire un système qui a les
chances de revenir à son état initial
or c'est précisément la conclusion
qu'ont fait ces scientifiques il était
impensable d'imaginer que la terre
puisse revenir à l'état précédent qui
prévalait depuis le ghana glaciation et
que nous avions amené l'état de la terre
dans ce nouvel état qui fait qu'on est
d'appeler cette fois ci
possible alors bien sûr maintenant je
souffle froid
il n'y a pas de crise environnementale
mais il ya évidemment des problématiques
environnementales pressante
il ya toute une constellation
problématiques environnementales y en a
eu que la star qui domine
absolument toutes les autres
problématiques et c'est évidemment
changement climatique
elle est à l'agenda constant des médias
également alors à l'agent talent de
nombreux politiques
elle est certes importante mais ils font
bien quand même s'intéresser à d'autres
problématiques qui ont des comptes et
qui permettent de développer et d'amener
les élus et des idées très très
surprenante et j'aimerais vous en
présenter une
c'est le thème de la biodiversité cette
biodiversité est en effet son étude son
évolution montre qu'elle est tel
qu'actuellement on peut la comparer à
des phases très important de l'histoire
de la terre un juge aux log alors
forcément j'ai cette approche et en
particulier à ce qu'on appelle des
extinctions massives
en effet notre planète depuis au moins
600 millions d'années a connu cinq
phases d'extinctions massives
alors qu'est ce qu'une extinction
massive je vais vous montrer ça je vais
vous la montrer sous la forme d'un
graphique je suis désolé j'ai une
formation scientifique à la base mais
c'est un graphique très simple sans
chiffres avec d'une part un axe qui vous
présente la biodiversité un autre axe le
temps et quand on étudie une extinction
reste une une évolution de l'évolution
de la biodiversité et le développement
d'une extinction massive on constate
dans un premier temps que la courbe est
relativement plate ya une forme d'
équilibre entre apparitions et
disparitions des espèces vivant puis
sous l'effet d'un stress igloo
écologique globale on va voir cette
biodiversité chuté très fortement pour
atteindre un point minimum puis ensuite
à tous les cas remonter donc la vie
reprend toujours ses droits alors ici
c'est un cas général et dans le cas
général on considère et on parle d'
exactions massives
quant au minimum 75% des espèces
vivantes disparaissent de la terre dans
un temps inférieur à 2 millions d'années
et le cas général et ça a été démontrée
pour chacune de ces cinq experts
extinction massive
ça a été lié de près ou de loin au moins
à du volcanisme
ça c'est la situation classique d'une de
ces cinq extinctions massives mais enfin
elles se sont toutes déroulées un petit
peu différemment et je vous propose de
vous intéresser à une
particulier qui est très célèbre parce
qu'elle a vu pas et c'était la cinquième
de la dernière elle a vu la disparition
des fameux dinosaures
c'était il ya 65 millions d'années alors
j'ai laissé la course précédente et ya
65 millions d'années ce qui s'est passé
dans un premier temps on a eu d'abord un
vocaliste extrêmement important qui en
effet a fait diminuer très fortement
l'université puis ensuite ultérieurement
cerise sur le gâteau ou goutte d'eau
stick goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase
on l'a eue chute d'une météorite et là
vous avez vu que le système est encore
va beaucoup plus vite c'est à dire on le
voit d'abord la pente
elle est certes ride mais encore avec la
météorite la pente de la courbe donc la
vitesse de la chute de la biodiversité
avec encore plus rapide
ça c'est ce qui s'est passé à la fin des
dinosaures
si c'est la situation qui a mené à la
fin des deux heures et puis finalement
comparant cette situation j'ai reporté
en gris l'accord de la famille en or
avec ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas vécu la
sixième extinction fort heureusement des
espèces vivant mais nous sommes dans une
situation amorcé qui présente deux
caractéristiques on voit ici c'est la
courbe en rouge on voit que cette courbe
est plus raide que la courbe d'un
système volcanique classiques sont
massives
autrement dit actuellement les espèces
vivantes disparaissent plus rapidement
que les disparaissait de la faim des
dinosaures l'autre observation
intéressante c'est là la honte de cette
forme elle est tout à fait similaire à
la courbe que connaît la chute de la
biodiversité faute à une chute de
météorite donc là quelque part il est
convenable de les comparer alors de ces
observations de ce lien vous présenter
on peut retenir trois choses d'abord
actuellement les espèces vivant
disparaissent au moins aussi rapidement
que le disparaissez autant dinosaures
les dinosaures et ça j'en profite pour
vous dire n'ont pas disparu tous un
grand barbecue planétaire allumé par une
météorite dans un temps très court
ça a quand même pris du temps de faire
disparaître nous aurais quand on
considère cette durée et qu'on leur
ramène aux vitesses on connaît
maintenant le phénomène actuel est au
moins aussi rapide que ce qu'il a lu
l'un et à l'autre la deuxième
conséquence importante c'est que les
cinq grandes extinctions qu'on a connus
que la terre a connu jusqu'à présent ont
toujours eu une origine géologique
volcan et où météorite en plus ici pour
la première fois sur un temps très court
la cause est d'origine biologique c'est
nous homo sapiens et d'où le nom
anthropocène qui a été choisi pour cette
période géologique entreprises
signifiant une troisième conséquence
imaginons que nous arrivions à
l'extinction massive ce qui est tout à
fait certains calculs le prédisent
en quelques milliers d'années ce qui est
juste une fraction de seconde à
l'échelle des temps géologiques on parle
plus de deux millions d'années
une quête milliers d'années imaginons
qu'elle se produise c'est ce que je
reproduis entre étiez ici nécessairement
n'ayez aucune crainte la vie avec un
grand v de toute façon va s'en sortir
un coup de chaud elle va s'en sortir la
ville mais ce qui est en jeu
fondamentalement de l'anthropocène c'est
pas la survie de la vie avec avait
majuscule c'est bien la survie de nous
et bien notre humanité en effet on
pourrait naturellement puisque je viens
de développer la question de la
biodiversité et que le climat qui est
aussi une question tout à fait grave
être tentés de vouloir associer ces deux
thématiques et se dire finalement à
celle de l'université est due à la chute
au changement climatique
eh bien non en fait le climat jusqu'à
présent n'est que très très peu
responsable la chute de la biodiversité
évidemment que si le climat venait à se
dégrader très fortement
il aura un impact plus grand encore ce
chu la biodiversité mais pour l'instant
ce n'est pas lui qui explique la
situation
donc du coup vous voyez qu'on a un
problème pour apprendre ces questions
dures mentale parce que je vous présente
la question dabo diversité qui vint et
finalement on n'arrête pas avant une
vision globale de ce qui est en train de
se passer sur terre pour apprendre les
la question d'une manière générale les
questions climatiques il faut passer par
autre chose et les mêmes scientifiques
n'ont travaillé sur cette question de
l'entrepôt scène que je cite au début eh
bien on proposait une espèce de tableau
de bord globale qui présente neuf
thématiques environnementales qu'il
convient de surveiller en priorité c'est
pas exhaustif mais en tout cas c'est
neuf là il faudrait surveiller
il s'agit évidemment du changement
climatique de nouvelles entités
chimiques en l'occurrence
imaginez par exemple pour un sujet qui
maintenant est connu par le grand public
c'est la question des perturbateurs
endocriniens
ces soupçons qui interfère avec le
système hormonal
il s'agit également la couche d'ozone
les aérosols les particules en
suspension d'un poster de
l'acidification des océans de cycle
azote et phosphore deux substances
chimiques abondamment utilisé dans un
juste dans l'agriculture de
l'utilisation de 12 de l'utilisation du
territoire et enfin évidemment de la
biodiversité et pour chacune de ces
thématiques environnementales
il a été définie d'abord une limite une
limite en deçà de kehl le système
devrait pas être trop en tout cas la
thématique environnementale elle même ne
va pas être trop perturbé mais au-delà
de cette limite c'est le deuxième cercle
ici en gras concentriques une plus à
l'extérieur
là ce n'est plus une limite c'est un
seuil au delà de ce seuil le système
devient complètement incontrôlable et on
ne sait pas du tout ce qui peut se
produire et il peut se mettre en place
des dynamites des rétroactions négatif
aux systèmes terrestres
alors je vous laisse quelques secondes
considérez celis 9000 planétaire et
c'est d'imaginer lesquels sont les plus
lesquels on en rit pour lesquels on
aurait outrepassé les limites voire les
seuils rapidement les jours donne la
réponse
trois possibilités d'abord il ya des
limites pour laquelle les calculs
c'était fin d'intervention qui sont
présentés ici pour lesquels les calculs
non pas qu'ils n'ont pas payé fait pour
l'instant à l'état des recherches
on sait juste que c'est des thématiques
sont sérieuses qu'il faut surveiller les
nouvelles entités chimiques sont parfois
présentés comme des bombes à retardement
l'effet sur les systèmes hormonaux sont
terribles depuis 40 ans on a perdu près
de 40% la fertilité masculine pour cette
raison mais ça n'a pas été calculé
considérons ce qu'ils ont été calculés
deux de ses limites pour deux pour trois
décès de ces thématiques
on est encore dans le vert ça veut dire
qu'on n'a encore pas dépasser la limite
couche d'ozone ont ces deux extrêmes
projet un processus à peu près réglée
l'acidification des océans
alors là on est encore de ça de la
limite mais en fait elle va grandissante
on pourrait très bien
relativement rapidement la dépasser
l'eau douce encore pas trop mal quand
bien même on sait que dans certains
endroits dans le monde c'est un problème
très très sérieux
maintenant il ya des limites physiques
sont en jaune
ce sont des limites qui ont été dépassés
des valeurs qui ont été dépassés
évidemment changement climatique et à
lui seul ce schéma résume bien la
question climatique actuel nous avons
dépassé la limite planétaire en termes
de changement climatique mais nous
n'avons pas passé le seuil ça veut dire
qu'il est urgent au niveau international
de prendre les dispositions nécessaires
pour nous surtout pas outre passer ce
seuil
nous avons des effets de changements
climatiques mais c'est encore une
situation gérable la même chose si ce
n'est de l'utilisation du territoire et
c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait l'actualité
de notre pays puisque une décision a été
prise récemment sur cette question au
niveau de la suisse c'est un paramètre
extrêmement important il faut savoir que
c'est le principal paramètre qui
explique la chute de la baie diversité
donc le mitage du territoire
d'utilisation du territoire est un
paramètre extrêmement important et puis
de limites on a défoncé on est on a
dépassé les seuils évidemment la
biodiversité
je vais pas revenir là-dessus mais les
sigles azote et phosphore avec deux
choses
l'azoté le phosphore pause épreuve
d'agriculture tout notre système mondial
agriculture est basé sur ces ressources
là or le phosphore ne serait-ce que le
phosphore est une ressource qui vient dé
production minière est donc une
ressource limitée et nous devrions dans
une quinzaine d'années atteindre le pic
de production
donc ça veut dire que par la suite on va
rentrer dans des phases de pénurie de
fass forme potentiellement de pénurie de
production alimentaire
mais plus encore donc c'est des gens
sont très calmes et plus encore azote et
phosphore participent à une forme d'
asphyxie d'asphyxié des mers et des
océans et étant donné qu'on est on a
largement outrepassé le seuil beaucoup
de scientifiques s'inquiètent de la
situation parce qu'on pourrait voir des
mers d'abord des mers intérieures du
type méditerranée s'appauvrir très
fortement en oxygène et donc voir toute
la vie qui la contient fortement diminué
ça a évidemment des conséquences
désastreuses en termes de biodiversité
de chaîne alimentaire mais évidemment à
court terme aussi en termes économiques
puisque vous imaginez bien que sont des
ressources très importantes pour les
économies voilà pour une vision bezat
voyez que 7 7 7 ce tableau de bord c'est
une sorte de tableau de bord nous permet
d'avoir cette vision globale sommes
maintenant tout ça c'est bien joli mais
au fond ça nous donne des chiffres ça
nous montrent des évolutions mais ça ne
nous dit rien sur le fond soient les
raisons qui sont en jeu derrière cette
problématique
alors on pourrait évidemment se dire eh
bien tout ça c'est la population au 20e
siècle la popularité toujours
actuellement la population connaît une
croissance extraordinaire et c'est la
raison du problème
c'est sûr que c'est un paramètre
important mais il n'est pas suffisant
pour comprendre où nous en sommes
actuellement la population mondiale est
certes un paramètre très important mais
c'est surtout un paramètre aggravant et
pour bien comprendre cette fois ci il
faut sortir de ce que je vous ai
présenté sortir du champ d'essences
naturelles des 60 du rhône mental et son
physique pour passer dans un autre champ
du savoir quel celui l'essence humaine
et sociale
vous savez c'est savoir qu'ils sont
souvent vivent des parce qu'ils ont des
solutions simples dans un monde complexe
car ces sons sont très importantes et
qu'est ce qu'elles nous disent elles
nous disent pas ce qui est en jeu sur
cette thématique environnementale relève
fondamentalement des représentations que
nous avons de notre environnement et de
notre manière de concevoir cet
environnement ces questions là elles
sont caractérisées sont elles sont clés
pour comprendre l'anthropocène et on
pourrait dire beaucoup de choses assumer
on peut résumer ces représentations que
nous portons dans notre manière de voir
l'environnement au travers d'un modèle
très simple et bigrement efficace c'est
celui qui consiste à voir le monde selon
un schéma très très simple donc en
partageant les choses soient de nature
soit de culture sans aucune possible et
et possibilités intermédiaire sans
concession les choses sont soit l'un de
l'autre
donc par nature on entend tout ce qui
est déterminé c'est le monde extérieur à
nous qu issu des lois des lois physiques
intangible et d'ailleurs c'est sur cette
idée que la science moderne xviie siècle
et c'est là et ce sans fondamentalement
un cherche la science chercha à trouver
c'est à dire çà doit interrompre
temporairement de l'autre côté là la
culture c'est une liberté dans ce monde
liberté conçu comme une absence de
contraintes pour l'humanité et ses
sangsues manne essentielle nous enseigne
encore que cette idée très forte qui
conditionne notre manière de voir le
monde est apparu très précisément durant
la renaissance en occident elle s'est
peu progressivement développé en
occident pour ensuite s'exporter dans le
monde entier donc on est arrivé
maintenant dans une situation c'est pas
la seule manière de considérer notre
relation et c'est celle qui a commencé à
dominer les autres
et d'une certaine manière on peut dire
qu'une bonne partie de l'humanité vit un
peu comme si elle était en dehors du
monde en dehors sans gouvernement si je
peux prendre une à une mine une
comparaison avec la l'automobile c'est
comme si on avait un pied sur l'abus de
la d'embrayage et concédé
déconnecter you top alors comment
comment maintenant on peut aller plus
loin c'est parce que cette manière de
voir le monde c'est un peu comme des
lunettes
c'est un peu comme des lunettes comporte
depuis quelques siècles pour voir le
monde mais maintenant l'anthropocène
nous pousse à observer les limites de ce
modèle de voir le monde d'une autre
manière et je prendrai deux exemples on
sait très bien
deux exemples le premier par une
question
imaginez vous un seul instant qu'il y
ait une seule surface de la soupe de la
terre sur laquelle l'activité humaine ne
s'est pas manifesté et à mon avis c'est
pas possible
imaginez un seul instant les océans les
océans recouvrent à peu près plus de 70%
de la surface de la planète
nous savons que dans les océans flotte
énormément de plastique
nous savons que c'est un problème en
parle de septième continent
ces systèmes qui tourne sur les océans
de plastique mais les autres ne croyait
pas que c'est que ces plastiques ne sont
qu'en surface
en ce réseau la grande partie partie de
ses passes il tombe également au fond de
l'eau donc on se retrouve également avec
des fonds d'océan
en gros le 70% la planète qui est
recouvert de débris plastiques
donc comment imaginer et appliqué cette
séparation nature et culture mais un
autre exemple que j'aimerais prend ici
tiré d'un objet je trouve remarquable de
musées delà de la nature du valais à
sion
qu'est ce trophée de serre on pourrait a
priori imaginer qu'il s'agit d'une
oeuvre d'art qui aurait sa place dans un
musée d'art moderne
le problème c'est que ce cet objet en
fait vient d'un cerf qui est mort par
épuisement avec des bâtons dans ses
voiles des bateaux d'arrière danser voir
et qui a été découvert par sa vie de
l'achat donc on n'a pas une oeuvre
l'approprient purement culturel mais
d'un autre côté ce n'est pas non plus le
trophée de serre classiques présentés
dans parfois dans une j'ai deux sens
naturel puisque justement il a dit pic
et de serre dans la dent dans la tête
donc sur sûr c'est sur ces voies quant à
quelque part on a ici un objet qu'est
symbolique de notre peau saine il s'agit
d'un objet hybride qui n'est ni vraiment
nature ni vraiment culture donc vous
voyez que cette manière entreprises nous
ont très fortement les limites de cette
manière de concevoir notre relation à
l'environnement
alors pour conclure j'aimerais
j'aimerais conclure cette phrase est
quand même souffler un petit peu de
choses sur cette assemblée j'y crois
très fortement terminer cette phase très
fort des gardois qui dit le probable et
la désintégration
je vais pas continuer à suivre une année
assez dit en revanche en revanche
l'improbable est possible la
métamorphose c'est à dire considérons
égard morin le skite épuisé actuellement
dans notre manière de voir le monde
certaine manière c'est notre histoire
qui est épuisé il nous faut changer le
modèle il faut changer cette manière de
voir le monde et c'est un vrai enjeu
culturel mais en revanche
ça ne signifie pas que la puissance
créative créative humaine et l agoa mon
souffle absolument pas au contraire
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
de crise on voit émerger de plus en plus
des solutions partout dans le monde et
sont pour l'instant marginales mais qui
nécessairement parce que nous savons qui
nous aura blement et culture se
transforme non pas par des religions
mais par des lampes métamorphose le si
toutes ces initiatives qui sont en train
de naître
actuellement un peu partout dans le
monde seront probablement et pour autant
qu'on réussisse notre adaptation
anthropocène feront les ferments que
s'est tenue de ce nouveau rapport au
monde que nous devons inventer
donc il est clair que c'est que cette
puissance créative elle doit passer par
le développement de technologies
environnement environnementale ça c'est
une condition nécessaire mais ce ne sera
pas suffisant de compter sur la
technique pour réussir nécessairement on
devra aussi il faut accepter l'idée que
notre culture et notre et sa manière de
concevoir le monde puisse également
évolué alors coude en vol
du coup d'arrêt l'anthropocène c'est
surtout signal fort du nécessaire
métamorphose pour réussir notre pour
continuer l'aventuré
[Applaudissements]